[Music]
good morning everybody thickies that
gums stickers
thick hats
that's about it that covers it it is
monday morning january 10th lovely chris
los angeles morning out here in
calabasas
yep we're still considered los angeles
los angeles county unfortunately that's
not good when they decide to lock us
down like north korea anyways
how's it going kids
good weekend tim what'd you do this
weekend i did a lot man you did yeah we
talked about disneyland went to
disneyland for the first time in a long
time oh you went to disneyland
disneyland and
what day did you go to disneyland on a
thursday which i thought there's not
going to be that many people on a
thursday was it crunk as [ __ ] it was too
packed way too crowded and
like
did you get how they do it now like the
fast pass you have to buy ahead of time
like you can't do it like yeah so one of
our friends took care of all that so we
were able to get some stuff done but
then even then it was still i didn't go
on any good rides even when you had the
fast pass still a long line yeah i mean
no just even just to get there it was
complicated i'll say that much it was a
nightmare yeah and then did you have to
wear a mask the whole time pretty only
on when you go inside so outside you're
fine so when you're outside waiting line
you don't have to as soon as you enter
inside yeah some sort indoor area then
you have to wear it but wait what rides
did you go on
that's how i'm going i'm not even joking
that's how i'm gonna decide if you had a
good day at disneyland or not so we had
kids with us so are we on what ages uh
freaking two three four
okay yeah so literally just kid rights
like small world i forgot the other one
this is what's right in the world i know
and would you get dumbo in
just never wait for dumbo no not even
double uh dumbo would have been the
highlight but we didn't nothing yeah no
actual adult rides
you're [ __ ] up because you went with
uh friends who have kids yeah well my my
girlfriend's niece and or two nieces as
well that's fine yeah you [ __ ] up yeah
especially because you were going what
for your anniversary or some [ __ ] yeah
to your innovation you just gotta go
with all adults if you're gonna drink
and try to go on big boy so no haunted
mansion no splash mountain nope did you
go on the car ride
i think
we might have went on the car just the
yeah the we might have been on that one
no no not the cars it's a roller coaster
no no not that one on the little my
son's favorite little gas ones no
although the the [ __ ] and the goat
cart used to get sick completely yeah it
was wow what a terrible we drank like
crazy we snuck in alcohol as usual yep
yeah
that was pretty fun wow yeah uh did you
check out star wars world
damn it did we go there i don't remember
we did it you remember yeah you remember
that thing no matter what is packed with
just the uber star ward star wars nerds
you know i think that's the one ride
that we went on that uh yeah
it's it's almost like star tours but
better right yeah yeah
it's in the star wars war yeah yeah okay
i remember now
wow sounds like a rough day for you
it's cool dude so many t-fakie army were
out there too and they know those shoes
up yeah that's cool yeah really cool
were you wearing
i am trim from finally kids i literally
wore that firelink kit jacket the red
one no no the cool one from root to
fight yeah the original one the red one
oh no green green of the original
best jacket of all time yeah
so yeah i wear that all the time though
i love that jacket yeah i love that
jacket i got to wear it more yeah so you
went to disneyland it's a busy day
mm-hmm what else and i got pedicure you
got a pedicure with your first time yeah
have you ever done it i've done it it's
awesome isn't it uh your feet feel so
much nicer
i i don't i need my feet rough for the
like running and riding biking because
when they take them and make them like
soft then
yeah well i don't do any of that stuff
so you got a pedicure disneyland yeah
just chilled after that pretty busy
weekend yeah
casey anything fun i played golf
saturday
casey plays a lot of goals all new high
right new record yep
personal best meaning
uh like my lowest score your low score
was what so i shot five over five over
give me help
help me out here five overs so you so if
so par c shot five over par yeah for the
course which is good yeah like you'd be
on the pro tour if you could shoot par
or under yeah they consistently shoot
way under way under yeah they're insane
they're like minus one minus three
like there was a tournament over the
weekend tournament of champions and over
72 holes so they played four times
thursday too much golf you had too much
gold but he was collectively 34 under
that's impressive that was insane
you love golf balls balls deep in golf
you have the clubs and everything
obsessed your own [ __ ] yeah damn who do
you go with
uh all the homies got him to golf over
kovit and i got back into it because
they got into it a lot of people got i
got into i got uber into bike riding
some people got into golf you know who's
balls deep in golf right now santino
he's pretty good too santino plays a lot
during covid tony hinchcliffe plays a
lot of golf
people got weird like hobbies in during
the pandemic i think young jamie too
they were talking about how you oh yeah
yeah he's a ponytail now
crazy huh it's [ __ ] lit yeah
um
i'm trying to say i did some bowling it
was my uh
is my girl's brother's b day so we took
him to bowling alley and uh little bosti
was scared to ball so he'd only go if i
was holding his hand so i brought him up
there
uh
where's that
i'm the refreshing arrow oh there you go
look how tiny he is i know
he almost fell boom strike dads knows
what's up
long alleys like hey sir your shoes and
you're like i know sick right hilarious
no the bowling shoes they had were too
slippery they're like way too slippery
so i was like i'm just rocking my own
[ __ ] nobody was there i'm like they
don't care dude those aren't going to
mark up the thing look how small bosses
he's got you're rocking he's rocking a
ponytail too he has a ponytail
straight up man bun ponytail yeah
what what uh griffin said glad you
didn't get confused in touch kid no sir
no sir ct's not that bad yet
uh i grew up i grew up bawling though
man my dad took us like damned every
week bowling shooting archery but it
always says archery archery that's
awesome shoot a lot of bowling arrows of
course
of course we went to uh
malibu cars and coffee this guy has this
law ferrari that's probably the most
impressive car there
i would say tiger's bigger than the
grown man in the background yeah for the
most part
but uh yeah the cards are [ __ ]
knocked man the the amount of money
people have like that law ferrari you
know
three million dollar car four million it
looks just to get it at msrp which even
though i'm allocated ferraris you to
allocate a law ferrari i don't know what
you got to do you have probably been a
program for like 10 years the guy gave
the worst parking like parked it on
where the fire truck was red so then
like to get up like so many cars were
getting so close to them like what are
you doing dude there's some dude there
if you go over to the lambo i'm not a
lambo guy i know cars i don't i don't
like the huracan
the ventador this was a special this is
the race lamborghini this is basically
their version of the gt2 rs or the
ferrari pista that's their race version
there's only like a few of them in north
america
and i was talking like that just looked
like a normal dude nor dad beard you
know whatever just he's like yeah i was
like uh which one is that he's telling
me and he's like we just got it and uh
that color came from the factory he's
like we have five of them like what the
[ __ ] dude just insane
i don't know why he's posing like that
thinks he's so cool but whatever his
shirt matches it sorta yeah it does it's
almost the exact same color
yeah he loved it man he loved it so
uh as far as the fight world's going man
yeah we uh you know they're edging us
yeah you at least got a good fight night
the main event is lit as [ __ ]
um outside that the they're just
again they're edginess to freaking
january 22nd we will have a fight
companion uh i have some bad news though
christos um
he might have ct from playing college
basketball
because he the night of fight company he
agreed to it a month ago so we figure
everything out promotional stuff my guy
reuben makes all the graphics then last
on friday night he's like dude i'm such
an idiot i'm in tampa on stage on the
22nd like
very cool thank you for that
so he's out but uh we'll find a dope
replacement we'll find somebody for that
one so i'd be crystalia bryant cal
myself and special guest for the cowbest
fight companion that is january 22nd
on thick boy only and thick boys rolling
man you guys tuned in to last week's uh
shop show the first one on my own this
will be the second one that the squad is
producing and it uh from what i hear on
the comments fans are digging the uh the
upgrade shout out to the fans for for
phone yeah man we'll check the fans for
following the thick boy ways the
scribers is going through the roof at
thick boy and we also launched super
cast cal and i did a uh calabasas fight
companion classic the first one was
kellen and myself
uh watching my fights three of my fights
this week we have sugar shawn on we also
have sugar shawn for uh food truck this
week this will be the first food truck
that my team's producing which will also
release on thick boy only so
um it's gonna be dope man it's gonna be
i'm super excited but super cast will
have all that ad free
and i get the question like oh why don't
you go with patreon so many people on
patreon
oh super cast cause
if you the fans who have subscribed
already if you sign up for it it's so
much easier you literally play pay with
your apple pay so everyone pays with
apple pay you don't have to there's
another way to pay but if you have apple
pay which most of us do pay with apple
pay
and then the feed automatically goes to
you don't have to subscribe
something new it just uploads the
premium link to already your rss feed
so
if you subscribe to the shop show or
fire in the kid it automatically gets
uploaded ad-free along with the original
one that has ads in it so you don't have
to do anything it just automatically
uploads it and then we email you a link
to all the videos ad free so if you
missed the calabasas classic fight
companion with me and brian break down
the crow cop krista tusher chase gormley
fight you get that ad free
you get the find a kids ad free get
bonus content you get a ton of stuff on
there so uh that's why i went with super
cats man because so much easier to
navigate man so much easier i think
they're the future
and uh if you haven't subscribed yet go
to thickboy.supercast.com
and you can subscribe there and that
thing is a move in
the things are moving baby
there you go chin bring that bad [ __ ]
up
and we gave the uh
we gave the uh audio for free just give
you a little taste of it dude just a
little taste five dollars
for the thick boy bundle
five dollars you get the shop show you
get the ama you get the classic
companions food truck diaries cowbest
fight companion all that stuff man
exclusive giveaways you get custom art
so the
companion art that you see the all the
boys will autograph
um
we have uh cards on there my rookie
cards were autographed and then the
fighter bundle which is eight dollars
you get all that plus firing the kid
advanced notices on all my merch so you
guys get access to the merch first we
have our all our old episodes uploaded
there for finding the kid and the shop
show so it's pretty cool man
it's pretty freaking cool check out
super supercast thinkboy.supercast.com
enjoy them bundles baby enjoy them
freaking bundles take four or three c's
i know people know but some don't so
thick boy with three c's yeah anything
outside it continues dicey for you man
you start just you saying thick and
thick boy you get some weird stuff on
your computer i don't know i don't know
what road you're gonna go down you see
some just thick
fat dude oiled up probably in a thong
you're like this isn't what i signed up
for well we told you three c's there's
nothing i can control outside the three
c's
let's take a little break from the fight
shenanigans on the shop show cause man a
lot of you bros out there you're losing
your hair man i see on when i'm on the
road
when i do spots around la
dudes are coming up to me first thing i
notice is your hair if i'm notice it
your girl definitely knows it if you're
single let's take care of that man
here's some stats right two out of three
bros will experience some form of hair
loss by time to 35
more than 50 million dudes in the us
suffer from male pattern baldness it
ain't good man that's why my friends at
keeps offers a simple stress-free way to
keep your locks alright it's low-cost
treatment start at just 10 bucks per
month keeps offers generic versions
discrete little package shows up proven
results keeps has more five star reviews
than any of its competitors prevention
is super key here achievements can take
four to six months to see results so act
fast if you're ready to take action
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
shobb that's k-e-e-p-s dot com shob to
receive your first month of treatment
for free that's keeps k-e-e-p-s com
s-c-h-a-u-b to your first month free
keeps.com shop this episode of the shop
show is also brought to you by better
help listen man is there something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
i know you made your goals for 2022 and
you're like i just i need something to
get me over the hump i'm just not
feeling like myself you need to talk to
real real people that can help and
that's where better help comes in they
will assist your needs and match you
with your own license professional
therapist professional is key here quit
talking to your friends and family get
with a professional
you can start communicating under 48
hours not a christ line it's not
self-help it's professional therapy done
securely online all right service
available worldwide baby you can log on
to your account anytime send a message
your therapist you get timely and
thoughtful response plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone session
sessions so you won't ever have to sit
in a comfortable waiting room all right
like traditional therapy we don't need
that man it's much more affordable than
traditional offline therapy and
financial aid is also available so what
are you waiting for man better help want
you to start living a happier life today
visit betterhelp.com shop that's
betterhelp h-e-l-p and join over 2
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health
all right mental health with the help of
an experienced professional in fact so
many people have been using better help
to recruit an additional therapist in
all 50 states special offer for the shop
show listeners you get 10 off your first
month why not try it why not man i
promise you it's going to help go to
betterhelp.com
s-c-h-a
betterhelp.com shop uh you do have a
fight night and this on saturday chin
yep at 4 p.m pacific 4 p.m at the apex
yeah
4 p.m that makes a little dicey but all
right i'll take it i'll take it
i'll take it because it doesn't run to
me finishing my binge watch of dexter
can't get enough of dexter right now you
know dexter's uh
it says it's in miami but actually gets
shot in marina del rey in long beach
sorry to break it to you guys
um but yeah so you have a great main
event in calvin keator and giga chikazee
great fight finale fight has fight of
the year written all over it to be early
in the year so people might forget about
it as they vote for the fights of the
year but this one has
all the capabilities of being just such
a great [ __ ] knight uh i love giga
he's an absolute [ __ ] monster
absolute [ __ ] monster calvin's
obviously my boy love calvin
you know he's from the uh what they call
new england cartel
so they're doing the damn thing man
calvin you know
had a tough outing his last one but this
this is a another tough fight for him
man but where he's at makes sense
uh i'll you know i like brandon roy out
roy val
he's fun on there jake collier chase
sherman's always good i can't really
treat sure i'm still doing the goddamn
thing yeah kurt mcgee still doing it
brian keller boy brian kelleher yeah
boom
not this card's not gonna blow your
[ __ ] hair back that main event well
though the main event will
the main event well and in that division
two obviously you guys get the news that
max holloway pulled out of the fight
which is such a shame i was looking so
[ __ ] forward to that fight
i he pulled up he pulled out early too
because i think before they even made
the poster when the ufc was announcing
it he came out like hey i'm not i'm out
injury force is my fault apparently it's
the same injury yeah it's undisclosed
but yeah he says the previous injury
such a shame i love max i really want
him to beat volkanowski
i hate to be biased there but i really
wanted to get that win yeah he deserved
one of them for sure for sure
um and holly's just been on a [ __ ]
tear and they think fight of the year oh
damn near him uh yaya rodriguez
so now it's like
they're trying to figure out who's gonna
fight alexander volkonovsky and
everyone's kind of throwing their
hat into the sweepstakes to fight off uh
volkanovsky
so then um
yaya rodriguez go up
he put do i really need to raise my hand
at dana white heal up quick
i had respect for you before but now
[ __ ] you you little [ __ ] you know i'm
next
you coming off the laws dude
and then uh booking us but mate comp
down you know fight once in over two
years and are coming off a loss if
zombie doesn't happen you might get
lucky so that's the talk right now
would be uh korean zombie yeah green
zombie
um
let me go to korean zombies wikipedia
because he's coming out he has he has
that win over your boy we bet on it yeah
yeah right
so here's that one which is a good one
that's a good [ __ ] win
so remember he got pretty beat up
against brian ortega yeah
um
the thing is he also he lost to yay
rodriguez although he's beating his ass
but yeah
doesn't matter still a loss still lost
he's he's won three i was last five he's
coming off a win
loss to brian ortega he definitely has
more of an argument than yay rod yeah
red beans it's this weird arrogance he
has
yeah it's a it's kind of weird too
because he cusses a lot like overly
cusses a lot because he's like the f
word a ton it's like it's almost like
trying too hard
maybe make because this english is
second language i don't know so because
sometimes when people get nervous they
just see comics who if they cuss a ton
they're nervous i'm trying to fill the
space if you see a comic who just cusses
non-stop
most the the old head's like dude you
gotta quit cussing so much even dirty
comics like dude the cussing's taken
away from everything
um i'm with you on the ego thing though
that's something about it
yeah just he just rubs me the wrong i
don't know he just rubs people the wrong
way i guess a little bit yeah when he's
like do i really do i even need to raise
my hand it's like
huh
we weren't even considering you yeah i
guess raise your hand
sure oh you think you're a shoe-in
you're coming off a loss
and to vokanovsky's point you haven't
you felt like once in three years dude
now henry cejudo i'd be all about
that'd be henry cejudo's the fight but
the fight when is the fight february
um let me see
ufc 272
yeah march march
it's not to march so hulu could
definitely do it obviously he's staying
in
somewhat decent shape because he helped
you know he helped all these fighters
out he helped uh
your boy whaley out your girl waylay out
he helped john jones so he's staying in
shape there
um
henry cejudo volkanovsky to me makes the
most sense but the problem is
is
vote
cejudo said only come back if they if
the money's right
so he if he wanted if he really wanted
this fight and do it for his legacy
which if he became a three division
champion
there's no argument in any facet he'd be
the greatest of all time hands down
because i know we call him the triple
champ
you know with the olympics which you
could so if you call them the quadruple
champ that's cool but to be a triple
champ in the ufc's on [ __ ] heard of
if anybody can do it henry cejudo i do
think you'd be a handful for volkanovsky
still
it's a tough [ __ ] fight to call the
other
are going to destroy anybody korean
zombie gets eaten [ __ ] alive sorry
chin uh
yaya rodriguez light cake sure he gets
eaten alive anybody else who's trying to
get in there is going to get eaten alive
by volkonovsky on a short notice
henry cejudo makes the most sense
definitely going to get the attention of
the casuals as well so it's going to do
well
but
henry cejudo
has said they it's just not worth it for
me to fight like they need to throw more
money at me and the ufc just
unfortunately doesn't need him
it's a shame
because if anybody should be get paid at
henry cejudo because
the the history and the legacy for him
to be a triple champion the first ever
triple champion in the ufc
you just
you just wish the ufc would be like
because they don't want here's the thing
if you're a business owner you don't
want to set the presidents that
we're going to pay guys if they if they
hold out long enough and they make a big
enough fuss we're going to pay these
guys you don't want to set that standard
so i don't know if henry cejudo the
demand for him to come back is enough
for dana white to bend the knee as henry
sudo says and pay him throw the bags at
him and also i don't know how much he's
asking for
i bet it's not unreasonable i bet you
it's not unreasonable could they afford
it god yes well they do it probably not
which is a [ __ ] shame but i would
imagine i think his managers ali i would
imagine they're talking ali right now
ollie's close with dana so there could
be something there
but name name another fighter that they
would
you know that that
has
was his career earnings yeah
we can't go through the first one
because that's that is what it is but
so his last fight he made
a flat fee of 350 and then 40 000 fight
week incentive pay
before that he got his highest payday
when he fought uh well he made 440 000
um he got
50 000 performance of the night bonus
and 40 000
so when he became uh
the double champ he made 440 grand
now for most people they're like that's
a truckload of money for a guy of his
caliber and his credentials that's
nothing
but
but again i try to put myself in the ufc
shoes they're saying how many how many
pay-per-views did he sell now that was a
fight night so there's no pay-per-view
incentive there um the ufc 238 was a
pay-per-view
um
him being a champion get some
pay-per-view points so he he made more
than 440 000 because he's gonna get
pay-per-view points there so although it
says 350 and 440 he's gonna get
pay-per-view points because that ufc
who's the main event on that for 230
mris
see
so let's see
so he was the main event so is henry
cejudo marlo mariah's
yeah
tony ferguson cerrone peter young jimmy
rivera
no there's no i mean yeah he
he probably didn't make too much money
off that
what were the pay-per-view buys on that
oh it's that's what the ufc is gonna
do well total gate was two mil let's see
you see he's in chicago sixteen thousand
species sold out chicago arena for sure
what
um
oh that's 178.
oh that's one that's conor mcgregor oh
there it is scroll down scroll down
uh prelims set a record of 964 000 views
here we go
translate into more
translated into more than 250 yeah 250
is not i think their bare minimum to
make some money is 300 grand
on pay-per-view 300 000 they do 300
grand they're not crying on monday
so you know it's a 250 000.
stuff
because i'm sure ali who's negotiating
for henry right now is going look at
this he can be triple champ you see he's
going yeah but look at his pay-per-view
pull
so that's their argument
it's it's a real shame i hope they pay
him man because
name another fight you'd want to [ __ ]
see
for volklanovsky yeah
249 ferguson gateshead was the
headliners main event that was
so he was on the same card so he
probably made some good money on that
because it as a champ you can get
pay-per-view points
but then ufc's get are you there you
weren't the main event
these guys are the reason it sold they
play a nasty game if you're a
businessman think what you would do you
know i'm not saying it's right i'm just
saying
tell me [ __ ] apple couldn't pay the
employees more there of course they can
we all use apples quit your cried um
korean zombie is currently the front
runner by a margin to replace holloway
all right
the korean zombie says let's do this
i think korean zombie make it
entertaining but it's eaten alive
uh yay rodriguez would make no sense i
don't think people would be
paying for that yeah
i mean if calvin cater and it's not
going to happen but kevin cater and giga
like say one got like a walk-off
knockout home run in the first round
like a minute into it with no injuries
especially giga he could get a shot at
it
outside that man i don't know what
they're gonna do
so this is
i can't i ca i could come out return to
anytime so i know you don't want me to
get lucky
also i've shown more heart in a single
fight than than you and all of yours who
disagree you know where to look up if
you want a real war if not keep
scrolling i'm sure you being the champ
can pick and choose
yeah dude he's not picking a guy he's
coming off a loss yeah he's talking like
he's this [ __ ]
has all this royalty it's so strange
i've shown more heart in a single fight
than you and all of yours who disagree
think about his last [ __ ] fight think
about ortega getting the [ __ ]
guillotine and the triangles like are
you kidding me dude it's nuts
volkanovsky is so [ __ ] good
yeah i don't know what they're gonna do
with us gotcha
speaking of the business model uh espn
raise the pay-per-view price once again
ooh
so this is the third time since endeavor
ufc acquisition so now it's 74.99
i know dude
it hasn't been that long either was like
a year so starting with the ufc 270 the
standalone pay-per-view price uh ufc
events and espn plus are again going up
with the streaming platform increasing
the cost of 75 bucks from its current
price of 70 dollars
also again a bump is the espn
pay-per-view package includes the ufc
paper event and a year subscription
streaming platform will now cost 100
bucks up from 89.
the change would mark the third price
hike since ufc struck a broadcast deal
with espn
i wonder if that's an espn thing or a
ufc thing
i i wonder why because they just had
their best year ever
because obviously when you increase you
see it in comedy too whenever you
include five dollars is a world of
difference we increase pricing from a
comedy touring standpoint if you
increase your ticket sales by five
dollars man
man man
it depends who you are but a lot of guys
see you know 30 to 40 dip in ticket
sales
um
then some guys what the do i won't
mention names some some comics very
famous comics when they're hot
what they do is they'll make prices like
120 300 a ticket
and people go but think about it 300
bucks for you and your girl 600 a night
plus dinner
let's say dinner's 100 bucks and look at
700 parking
then you get a babysitter look at almost
a thousand dollars go see that comment
and then they come back the following
year unless it [ __ ]
rocked your dick off you're probably not
coming back it's a dangerous game to
play man
it's a marathon not a sprint
and i'm so curious they actually have
the analytics and the people that do
this i just don't get why
after coming off the best year that
you've ever had now you increase it
yeah and people are having a tough time
making money right now too and plus like
the streaming stuff it just makes you
more tempted not me but people out there
i'm sure be more tempted to just stream
because this just cost too much that
money
yeah i wonder if they're doing it
because of all the legal streaming
they're like
for this man so much illegal streaming
potentially yeah
so espn plus can you see explosive
growth in crowd streaming market with
reported 17 million paid subscribers
a year over year increase of 66 percent
that's insane the cable channel espn
meanwhile continue to lose viewers with
76 million households down 24 from its
2001 peak of 100 million wow
yeah traditional tv is just not doing
well unless you're yellowstone holla at
your boy but you can get that on
paramount plus as well
yeah i i the the price increase man i
don't get it especially for their
demographic yeah 1836 males
blue collar really you know that's their
demo yeah i get like how much money you
need i know so like the jake paul stuff
it happens every once in a while but ufc
is like all the time so it's like it's
gonna be tough to buy all those freaking
pay-per-view buyers yeah our
pay-per-views
you agree yeah it's interesting
what else you got dude all right dude uh
this so apparently
nate diaz and dustin poirier were in
talks like it was gonna likely happen
very soon but then that turned out to be
not true now
the ufc is at least saying it's not just
that's because it's not a it's not a uh
dustin pour a thing it's a nate diaz
thing i think aero helwani blasted this
out
where so i just talked to ufc i said
what's up with the dustin prairie fight
i want to fight asap but they said
dustin sucks they don't want it sorry
dustin you suck hope to fight asap
though let's do this p.s oliveira you
suck too
yeah but um
yeah it's not obviously they're not
they're not saying no dustin sucks you
can't fight him
nate diaz only has one fight left on his
contract so they're dangling the carrot
over his face going we'll give you the
dp fight but you got to sign another
fight extension because they're not
going to let him
run off into free agency without getting
the trilogy fight with conor mcgregor
but all this say what you want about
jake paul but all this like
uprising and kind of fighting going on
with fighters saying you know not taking
fights stuff like that they see the
amount of money jake paul is making
going hold on dude
if i get out of this ufc contract
there's a chance they make that much
money well [ __ ] this
and how many people are watching
as many people are watching that as they
are if i fight some monster in the ufc
let me out of here ufc knows that so
they're dangling us overnight d is going
yeah we'll give you dust and pour a but
you gotta sign another fight extension
so you're not walking out here without
fighting conor mcgregor under our
umbrella that's what's going on
if you if you're nate though it's not a
terrible thing right you're gonna fight
dustin pour a any and then you get a
ride off in the sunset with a car
mcgregor fight
and then that jake paul fights not going
anywhere you can fight him after that
and you're you're only even bigger
let's say you were to beat dustin you're
gonna beat connor no then what's the ufc
gonna do
and then he rides out into free agency
and fights with jake paul and gets paid
all the money in the world like you're
set dude
if he's smart about it
dp connor jake paul we're done and i'm
out yeah [ __ ] you [ __ ] you you're cool
i'm out
so sign up for one more just one more
go if you guarantee me that doesn't pour
a early quarter one 2022 then i will
fight connor when he comes back in the
summer that'd be his comeback fight and
by october
november december i'ma fight jake paul
without the ufc that's what he's going
to do
and starbucks sucked up my drink
every if it's rare i don't say every
time i quit going to the one i always go
to because i go i don't want any cream
in my [ __ ] coffee you know say less
and then they put cream all the cream
it's just ice cr iced cream not to be
confused with ice ice cream
it's exhausting and then it takes so
long to drink i should go [ __ ] it and i
walk out of there and i never do
anything what else you got you don't do
almond milk anymore you still do that
too no i put a splash over it
i put a splash of it in literally i go
uh eight shot espresso
yeah i know you freaking over ice
shaking
over ice
and then i go i don't want any cream in
it just put the cream on the side there
you go you got it and then and
i remember
you're like do you want some coffee i'm
like yeah just the way you do it and i
tried that coffee i the whole day i was
jacked i was messed up really it
actually made me sick oh wow there's too
much damn caffeine there's absolutely
nothing for me anymore um there you go
all right uh let's go yeah this is cool
derrick lewis and ty tuivasa targeting
boyd called it did i not call this
mm-hmm
he said we want a fun fight you look at
the the heavyweight division right now
who he's lost to who he's beat this
makes the most sense it's a fun fight
tied to avasta's on kind of a tear i'll
see derek lewis fan favorite both fan
favorites the build-up's gonna be
[ __ ] great
i you know you never want to say this is
a for sure finish because the francis
and derrick fight but this is a for sure
finish
come on man
i what's the odds that derek lewis does
a shoei too
probably pretty good pretty good because
i remember he did that cup thingy and
then someone did a wanted to do a sheet
of cupcakes no he didn't he did throw it
in here
yeah
that's just thing is the cup chewy
that's the first time i saw it ever
happened just that big black dick and
that cup rolled up like gonzo's nose and
a ski mask and that dude wanted to
actually take a yeah
people are freaks yeah uh i [ __ ] love
this fight
love this fight
there's not a chance this goes past the
first round it's going to be insane to
watch man
you know
derek lewis does have some issues with
cardio tai teovasi can go man
but can he go and get hit by derrick
lewis and get into the second round
we'll see i love that fight i love both
of those those dudes
where's ufc 271 at houston that's why
it's going to be a big deal
derek lewis's hometown yeah because thai
two of us is coming over from what
australia new zealand or australia i
wish we'd get him earlier do a food
truck and do shoes together
but i doubt he still want to do the shoe
after that first oh yeah i do it i only
do it with him all right i'll only do a
shoe with tattoo vasa anybody else and i
almost threw up last time yeah i saw the
loogies man it was
it's
disgusting
but
that's such a fun fight
yeah not a chance that goes out of the
[ __ ]
second round i don't get crazy the first
you never know how they're gonna fight
because they both know they [ __ ]
start each other but the longer that
fight goes the better it is for ty yeah
but god them boys just [ __ ] slang it
man
love that fight they're the same guy
basically but one was born in australia
one was born in houston the same guy
two funny
funny personalities up the ass yeah
super lovable
and nothing
i'd say uh derek lewis has a little more
knockout power
but still yeah
great fight yeah
way to go uh ufc i almost said joe silva
he retired so long ago
all right also another australian new
zealand thing so this is apparently
official now i remember before uh style
bender when they booked the fight with
whitaker he kind of like put cavs
yeah the cap but it's apparently
official now uc271 and that's the poster
right there posters all right
that's all right
all right here's my idea for the poster
just
put both of them on and put their names
they could do some funner stuff my boy
reuben would crush that poster don't
steal him ufc
do not steal him
uh great fight yeah already looking like
a damn badass card that favorite oh
that's the ties on that card derrick
lewis
that's a great [ __ ] card
we'll have a calabash fight command for
that too
so many
great fight
uh this is pretty dope too so rafael
fazeev and
rda rafael and hawfield crime yep
who's the official haffiel of the ufc
top fight for dos angels
very tough definitely
rafael's killing it
i mean physique is killing it fazeeb is
a monster yeah
so that's february 19th you'll see fight
night
that was that the main the pay-per-view
is on the 12th and that fight nights on
the 19th i assume that's the main event
for the yeah ask fight night that's a
great fight it has to be five rounds
give me five rounds for those little
bastards
all right let's see here oh so going
back to the
korean zombie thing so i saw this on
so apparently
korean zombie after like late november
he did a blog on his on his youtube
channel or i think it's his youtube
channel but he said something about he
has a tear on his shoulder and that's
the only reason why i can't fight right
now so if he's saying that late november
that was in november yeah
he said it's a pretty bad you know
injuries it's gonna be tough but to get
a title shot he's gonna
he's in court zone shot that bad boy up
a video blog released at the end of the
november uh queen zombie revealed he
still suffer from serious slapped tear
in his shoulder that occurred in the
fight against dana ige i'm not going to
be provoked anytime soon
my coach seems some people around me
expect some type of provocative but i
didn't do it i shouldn't especially
right now my shoulders aren't in the
best conditions what sets me the most
are the comments
queen's on me stubborn waiting to fight
someone ranked higher than him this
isn't true at all i'm not fine because
i'm in pain if i wasn't hurting so much
i'd fight the first chance i got
seriously injured my shoulder during the
fight with ige a couple months ago i was
diagnosed with a slap tear and anyone
who has had a slap tear before knows how
painful it is slap stands for superior
labrium anterior posterior means your
shoulders labrum tissue is torn in both
anterior and posterior front and back
uh to the point where it connects the
bicep
it's a nasty injury which explains wow
that's not good yeah that's like late
november it's not that far away yeah
there's no way it's better
he definitely ain't beating broken off
you know
it's another reason like all right you
have a [ __ ]
korean zombie with one shoulder you have
[ __ ] yaya rodriguez coming off a loss
i guess i want to see those two
you know what i'm saying yeah like a
full healthy korean zombie probably not
beating volkanovsky one [ __ ] shoulder
sure is [ __ ]
but i'll tell you who'd give him a run
for his money henry cejudo pay the man
let's take another little break from the
shop show because this episode of the
shop show is brought to you by doordash
did you forget some at the store you
need your snackies you need your drinks
maybe you need a toothbrush deodorant
whatever it is get it in 30 minutes with
doordash dinner gotcha deodorant gotcha
morning pick-me-up you need that coffee
we gotcha whatever you need we got you
with doordash all right doordash
connects you with the restaurants you
love right now right to your freaking
door all right and now you can get
grocery essentials you need with
doordash too drinks snacks other
household items delivered in under a
freaking hour ordering super easy open
the doordash app choose what you want
from where you want it your items show
up at your door how about that with over
300 000 partners in the u.s puerto rico
canada australia can support your
neighborhood go to's or choose from your
favorite chain restaurants like popeye's
chipotle cheesecake factory cheesecake
factory menu way too long whatever for
limit time the shop show listeners and
viewers get 25 off and zero delivery
fees on the first order of 15 or more
when you download the doordash app enter
the code shop s-c-h-a-u-b that's 25 off
up to 10 value zero delivery fees on
your first order when you download the
doordash app in the app store enter the
code shop sch aub don't forget that's
code shop for 25 off your first order
with doordash subject to change terms
apply going back to henry ciudo he said
something super funny here
hey dana white give me a shot at alex i
would never cancel i met him we don't
believe in pulling out of anything
hilarious
keeps rolling we know ufc champ from the
usa i'm your best chance i'll put alex
to sleep faster than joe biden
also hilarious yeah
but yeah that's the fight for sure all
right it's such an easy fight to make
but again the pay thing i i don't know
what any student is asking for
yep no idea
uh another
rematch announcement so finally it's set
al james sterling versus peter yan kyoto
young excited
you're not or you are i'm not you're not
because you think peoria is gonna yeah
just destroy yeah he really literally
and i and i thought al germain was gonna
be the biggest issue stylistically for
yon but he just absolutely annihilated
him with the takedowns the pressure
i thought the wrestling be the
difference they see peter young just
tossed them around like ah [ __ ] dude
they just need to get that fight and the
division needs to move on
yeah to see who the real champ is that
was a terrible way to be a champion or
to win the championship very tough
but the and then the hate on al jermaine
it's like it's not his fault no
he didn't illegally knee him to the face
like what do you want those them the
rules them is the rules but the way he
was flaunting the belt afterwards that's
where the majority of the hate came from
yeah
all right god this coffee's [ __ ]
uh mike perry versus julian lane that
let me bang bro mania
knuckle up it's knuckle mania that's a
funny name man yeah it's you know
very
early 2000s late 90s knuckle mania
get your knuckle shirts in the back
that's a real fun fight though i think
mike perry and julian lane julian lane
how did i know that guy let me bang bro
he's crying oh that's right that's a
fighter julian's about to get lit up
yeah that's right we're gonna let you
bang but you're not getting gloves on so
we're going to let you bang but yeah
mike perry's give me a handful for
people definitely
all right a couple more fine
knuckle mania
thursday thursday
hell yeah i like how they do that who's
the cool matchup now
hill versus johnny walker
hill is a problem
hill's 11 no 9-1
he took out jimmy croot
paul craig that's a tough one for him
and then go to my boy um
johnny walker yeah
okay not the best that's three last four
santos be a decision
god ever since he did that [ __ ] the
world i know dude what the hell
yeah it's a tough fight for your boy
yeah johnny walker
okay your boy sean o'malley mentioned
this about cody garbrandt
i'll just show you right here
um so what what did he's on his own
podcast with his boy
so but dude cody's not getting that
fight when he said it you could see in
his voice he's like oh i want but that's
fight it's not happening it doesn't make
sense for him to say that you wonder if
that's ct he's been knocked out five
times in the last two years that fight's
not happening at least not next it just
doesn't make sense dude it literally
just doesn't make sense if you look at
his record no that's not next you're
telling me that makes sense knockout
knockout knockout o'malley made that
while a fight between him and cody would
be entertaining it doesn't nothing to
move his career forward he also
explained the upside and downside of
fighting the third year now i go out
there and i knock out code it's like
he's one
one in eight i lose cody i lose somebody
who's looked at that's kind of who sucks
now
i get we'll get into it on food truck
because i actually like that fight i
love that fight yeah
i see what he's saying but still you're
talking about a former champ super
famous too now
cody yeah cody's getting there yeah
for sugar though
i mean it's kind of this this is the
process of a young lion it's like
you're gonna get the guy
so your first like real vet you fight or
form a champ you fight
you're not gonna get a guy who's on a
streak
otherwise you're talking about title
shot next you're gonna get a guy who's
coming on the down and you're trying to
capitalize on his fan base so it makes
sense from a business standpoint and if
anything can beat him
why not do it cody garbrandt is a fan
favorite
former champion
you know this would
i get what he's saying he's going all
right if i beat him people like yeah
dude everybody's he's one out of his
last eight or whatever
same time too still danish fight still
hits hard you know
i get both sides yeah i would like to
see it though i think it's a good next
step for for him
all righty
rosenstrike versus martin martine tabura
that's a fun one it's a fun one
and this is interesting too
so joe schilling and two ufc vets jimmy
rivera and sam cecilia they're going to
be on the trailer's triad combat 2 card
that's the one with the you know is that
yeah the boxing but mma like standard
rules they're different you know
remember they had that whole video how
to explain it it's still kind of
confusing but too much yeah it's so
confusing why not why mess with things
but so the the vet is headlined by june
dos santos clash with pulev terrible
fight for jds i know dude i don't know
then belfort will face chad dawson
chad dawson used to be a monster i don't
know where he's at right now but if you
follow box and chad dawson used to be a
[ __ ] nightmare vitor on the sauce
though [ __ ] tough i know it's not i'm
not as scared for him against chad
dawson del santos poo left man i don't
know
i don't know so they had joe schilling
who also joined the card against uh
armin moroccan vic mercanti votes a 10-3
record five knockouts
and then jim rivera great good uh great
dude
yeah i love jimmy
fighting somebody sammy samuel tia
yeah i think the reason why these don't
get a lot of traction it's just
confusing like to like
it's already tough enough to pitch
somebody a a casual on mma like why are
they on the ground you know what i'm
saying like boxing's been around for
[ __ ] ever we understand boxing's two
guys trying to punch each other in the
head
mma is finally a main stay and it's
obviously gaining so much traction and
people kind of understand the ground
game you're not seen as as many boos
when it goes to the ground so when you
throw in something new it's like
it's like when tyson fury and francis
and ghana are talking [ __ ] to each other
on twitter and tyson goes yeah well box
in ufc gloves
okay well now it's even more confusing
so
why not just do a boxing match just do a
boxing that's that's cells but when you
when you cloud it with all right it's
give me a boxing match the ring's gonna
be different it's gonna be this
different and then we'll have these
rules and then then you gotta figure out
who's gonna sanction this [ __ ] thing
like who's gonna sanction a guy who's
never
fought in mixed martial arts but they're
wearing mma gloves what's the rules
what's the holding rules what's when
then the clinch what's the so it gets so
deluded
that people lose interest you know what
i'm saying like
it's like when you sign up for something
like evidence like when you sign up for
if it's not easy that's why i went with
super casts not to plug super casually
on this one if it's not easy and you're
asking people for money they're out man
eventually like
[ __ ] it i'll just whatever
just hey fury just do a you're a boxer
francis fancied himself as a striker
boxer he thinks he'll knock you out in
boxing we don't need there's no need for
you to go oh put on four ounce gloves we
don't need it dude just box for [ __ ]
sakes quit making it all
murky in the waters and then casually go
wow we're out make the most money
possible just box we want to see how
[ __ ] francis would do in a boxing
match we don't need mma gloves man you
don't need to do that this thing sells
itself you're [ __ ] it up by saying oh
let's put mma gloves on so he put who
would like to see me fight this beast
boxing rules ufc gloves not me
not me
it's too confusing i get it i'm a
degenerate i watch everything
for the casuals they're like wait why
are they in small gloves just do the
boxing gloves and then also
tyson is not used to fighting in those
small ufc gloves
so
the the jab the distance he's going to
fight different
just [ __ ] box dude also
for people out there too
as they had those boxing those are
10-ounce gloves with wraps on they're
not [ __ ] if you think a boxing glove is
better than an mma glove you're insane
they don't do much imagine that no
matter who you are whether you're
[ __ ] a tiny guy or you're [ __ ] 270
pound heavyweight in in tyson fearing
for estengano you have to take that 10
ounce glove and
stretch it over those big [ __ ] dick
beaters that they have for hands it's a
nightmare those gloves do nothing we
don't need mma gloves i don't need that
[ __ ] i don't need a triangle ring i
don't use a weird [ __ ]
eggplant sized ring i don't need any of
that just
tyson
just box dude
it sells itself you're [ __ ] it up by
doing this you're [ __ ] it up
we don't need to see you in mma gloves
beat francis in boxing then you guys do
the rematch if you knock you out or if
you knock him out and then maybe down
the road if you want to do this weird
mma
collab thing all right
just
box
because what happens if you box and
francis knocks you out
well then francis can go cool story dude
and then jump on over to anthony joshua
and deontay welder wilder and joshua
they're gonna be like wait he knocked
him out with him i make we're not
signing up for that and then those go
out the window so i'm francis said no
dude i'm gonna beat you in your own game
in boxing i believe i have enough power
or if i land one you're gonna get
knocked the [ __ ] out
this this isn't helping anything
and i think now because now what's
interesting when i told you guys
francis with his dilemma was with the
ufc you know him getting the jon jones
fight and obviously he's fighting the
for the championship uh january 22nd
where there's a calabash fight campaign
for that so with him fighting cyril gone
he's banking on himself winning that
fight
leaving the ufc and getting a fight with
tyson fury now what adds fuel to that
fire is tyson fear is kind of
acknowledging that he's down for it
which
pushes francis even more to go do that
so for francis he's like i'm sure it's
[ __ ] outside this contract extension
i'm gonna knock out sarah gone i'm gonna
get on the mic talk [ __ ] to tyson fairy
say i'm gonna beat your own game in
boxing sign the [ __ ] contract and
then you ride after the sunset you make
all the money in the world but if you do
this weird boxing ufc collab thing that
trailer [ __ ] it's just anthony and
joshua and wilder like what is this the
fans like what is this just bought them
if you want your [ __ ]
[ __ ] you money your paydays you fight in
boxing and then if you happen to knock
fury out which is gonna be [ __ ] tough
if you do then you [ __ ] parlay that
into the joshua in the wilderness of the
world but if you do this weird mma thing
we're [ __ ]
like i'm part of this team we're you
know what i'm saying
just box
but what i love for for france's stock
is tyson's entertaining him
i think it happened we're in this weird
world man i think
again say what you want about jake paul
but he is taking the fight game flipped
it on its head dana's come aft listen
dana only goes after people that he's
threatened by
he has all the money in the world so
when you're threatening his business
model which jake paul is doing people
see how much money he's making and they
you know they've tried to
do the same thing that politicians do
whether it's the left or right where
they try to you know downplay and
they're not they're doing terrible
numbers he only sold 75 000
pay-per-views they try all those antics
that pop the dirty scummy politicians do
the ufc tries that the brass try that we
all know it's not true how many people
actually bought into that [ __ ] 75
000 pay-per-views i think jay could
[ __ ] film himself taking a piss get
sell 75 000 paper use so we're not
buying that so he completely flipped the
game he's this he's this [ __ ] in their
armor he's the he's the cheat code in
this fight game and other fighters are
seen and france is the first guy to put
his money where his mouth is go nah i'm
seeing how much i could potentially make
i'm out man
and you gotta love that you gotta
support him
now it's gonna be terrible if you were
to allude to cyril gone on sat on
january 22nd all this goes out the
window
well that's why i'm kind of rooting for
francis what happens is francis winslow
isn't there like a clause champion
clause or whatever you gotta no he that
see that's i don't it used to be that
way where if you're a champion even if
it was your last fight by becoming
champion it automatically reneges the
deal so you have to defend it
but i i don't
it sounds like this is last one yeah
feels like it some some somehow markell
and the boys at ca shout out to ca
figured out where even becomes champ he
can go test free agency the ufc's down
to play like all right good luck the ufc
is crossing their fingers that he loses
because if francis is the first guy to
do this because you think about it there
hasn't been anybody like a super
powerful name recognition especially a
guy in francis who's in his prime and
heavyweight to go um
i'm going to win this championship fight
i'm going to go test free free agency
because everybody wants to do it
conor would make more which is insane to
say but kind of make more money doing
this nate diaz would make more money
there's only a handful and the ideas
make more money doing this
[ __ ] uh sugar sean would definitely
make more money doing this so ufc for
the first time
has a competitor where guys if they're
superstars it only works for superstars
where superstars can make more money not
fighting ufc it's
this has never happened before ever
where superstars can go well jake paul's
doing that i can do that
it's very interesting and if you're a
fan
and i hate it because it can come at the
cost of sarah gone losing the fight but
if you're a fan of fighters and you want
fighters get paid and you want
fighters to
not [ __ ] have to have youtube
channels and hold mitts when they're
[ __ ] 40 you want guys like francis to
win and set the path for other fighters
at his level to be able to leave the ufc
and make [ __ ] you money because they're
not making [ __ ] you money in the ufc
there's only one guy who makes [ __ ] you
money his name's conor mcgregor that's
it outside that nobody is riding off to
the sunset nobody francis has the the
ability now to knock out sirigon become
heavyweight champ and make real real
[ __ ] you money so you
you kind of got to root for francis here
hey and i lo it's nothing against sarah
gone but for the love of the game we
want francis to win for those reasons
because if he wins man you're getting
tyson fury you're getting wilder you're
getting anthony joshua next
and that sounds super fun you're getting
20 30 million dollars for francis
francis came from nothing you're talking
about a guy [ __ ] digging and what
[ __ ]
mines in africa man into in order making
20 and here's the thing too francis
gives back so francis does that it gives
them more resources to put resources
into africa where there's
france said this when i did uh
uh the free truck no not food truck hot
box with mike tyson he goes i wish i
could say i'm like this special freak
walking around in africa he goes
everybody looks like me man there's a
bunch of me i went there is he was yeah
i went we need to get to africa dude
so the ufc's dragging their ass doing
that obviously they have a bunch of
fighters put out but they're investing
so much in china
we could get in that i won't but with
africa if there's other francis and
ghana's walking around there and francis
has the ability from his success to give
back that community and build more
francis's dude a [ __ ] gold mine
francis could start his own fight league
there he has the resources
he could do his fight with
uh
fury in africa mimic the thrill in
manila but you have the ufc heavyweight
champion the hardest hitter of all time
fighting tyson fury type three to go
down there he's not scared of that [ __ ]
auntie anthony joshua
was born in africa
although he's english descent his mom
moved there when he's like eight but
he's
was born and raised in africa he was
like eight or nine then was raised in
england so the story between the african
bloodlines between anthony joshua and
france and ganu brilliant sell that
[ __ ] thing
for the king of africa francis anthony
joshua how many papers would that sell
worldwide
there you go markel
caa
it's brilliant
you got wilder waiting in the wings and
listen once they see the success of a
fury francis even francis de luz once
they see the success of that thing
again man you want to root for francis
if you want the fighters get paid
it's still only be a handful like the
ufc only a handful guys are making real
money it's going to be you you got to be
a undeniable superstar man
and the problem is
it's not the problem but those
superstars are making enough money where
they're not going to complain and come
out against the ufc
but but once they realize that the
potential how much money they could make
they're going to start coming out
you're going to start seeing a
i really think this this could do it
those unions that they've tried to start
all
toss that out of there it's like [ __ ]
wrangling cats it's not going to happen
but if the the superstars see like man i
can make
nine to ten times more money if i leave
the ufc then you're gonna get a change
and it starts with francis january 22nd
no pressure
uh let me ask you a question then so if
let's say
let's say that this stuff does start
popping off right so france is the first
one to do it and then other people
started trying to do that would be the
next one do you think the ufc somewhere
down the line would be like okay maybe
we should probably let them go like have
something in their contract part of it
yeah
well remember the ufc try getting the
box remember that they're trying to get
a boxing i think
boxing
so this could be kind of a thing but if
francis dips out and gets these huge
paydays against fury and joshua and
stuff like that what they're gonna do
because the reason the ufc
a they have the best talent b they also
have the best lawyers so their contracts
are bulletproof
there's going to be a stipulation that
contract that says we own your rights to
not only mma but boxing we're open to
doing boxing we see that as a
route that you can make money we want to
be part of it yeah
so i it won't happen right when francis
does it i think nate will still be able
to do it
with connor
it might get a little dicey for them
go but guys can do it yeah it starts
with francis no pressure francis but
that's why you should root for francis
again nothing against cyril gone it
could be anybody he could fight anybody
even if swiping my boy shane carla i'd
still say should probably root for
francis it's going to change the game if
he wins his fight and rides out of the
ufc
other guys are going to follow maz vidal
the only problem is
the guys i'm talking about outside
francis who's in his prime has a lot
left fighting left to do them these
other guys a little long in the tooth
right
nate diaz i don't know how many more he
has
connor don't know how many more he has
miles won't know how many more he has so
the only other guy who could do
something like this be a izzy
if he wanted to do that
jon jones
jon jones could definitely but
jon jones isn't going to box you know he
didn't seem like he no yeah
because it only works if you can get
another
mainstream guy to
headline with you to get [ __ ] you money
like who would jon jones fight to get
[ __ ] your money outside the ufc
he's not a knockout artist so he's not
going to box at a heavy weight he'll get
annihilate it's not his style his
style's being created the knees the
elbows that's what makes him special his
boxing doesn't make him special his
creativity his ability to adapt his
ability to mix in the wrestling with the
elbows and the punches and the kicks
that's what makes john special
those aren't going to correlate into
boxing so for john it doesn't work
what if they did john anderson silva now
that anderson's boxing it's like we
always wanted to see that now we kind of
get a version of it
it could be that
but to me that isn't like uh yeah that's
like it's not going to stop the earth
francis for fury stops the [ __ ] earth
we all pay for it francis or joshua
stops the earth francis wilder stops the
earth
i think diaz versus jake paul stops the
earth conor straight paul stops the
earth but then when you talk about you
know
there's not there's no big youtuber out
there who wants to fight who's a
heavyweight
that's going to stop the earth yeah so
something weird about jon jones you
don't you don't
see him in that same environment for
some reason even though he is he stops
the earth you know he stops
it's these weird
boxes you have to check in order to
cross over into that weird youtube
elite boxing level francis checks him
just because of his size he's a knockout
artist and he's in his prime so we can
see him fighting francis
then there's again i'd name the there's
only three other guys could really do it
izzy could do it but he's a little big
for like a jake paul stuff like that
he's still in his prime still has work
to do
so the chance you know there's no other
jake pauls out there logan paul's a
little bigger but i don't think logan
paul would sign up to fight izzy
he might
but the other thing is is he's not like
long in the tooth he's still he's he's
barely touched his prime like there's a
lot of fight left to do you know
there's just not a lot of like if he
goes out there and starts his whitaker
it's like
you gotta pray for that guy who beat him
and kickboxing goes through the ranks
and finally gets there
you know but he's too big for jake paul
it's just
you know it it's very rare to check all
the boxes where you can get one of these
youtubers or one of these boxing
grates interesting definitely that's why
you should root for francis
and just for fun here are the opening
odds if they did
fight france now is this in mma gloves
or is this straight straight boxing i
think just straight yes
minus 600 that's fine i'm oh yeah i'm
completely fine with that i it should
probably even be a little more than that
i would say um
the odds have been released to whether
or not the heavyweight super will even
take place
minus 400 no
you make decent money dude plus 2 2 or
50.
place your bets
it it's all predicated on what happens
january 22nd
and then the ufc is in a weird dilemma
because
you have francis if he were to just
completely annihilate sarah gone
so you're you're gonna pinch pennies
even on your heavyweight champ
who's the face of the heavyweight
division everyone loves to see fight
you're not gonna pay him
they don't want to pay him
you fighters all you are [ __ ] unless
you're conor mcgregor
the only other young guy who can do it
is sugar shawn yeah and he's a good
striker
good striker creative huge on youtube
huge on twitch
checks all the boxes has a huge
following young
friends with takashi yep
uh speaking of francis his old coach
ferdinand lopez
remember the sparring credit sparring
footage of surrogates and francis ingano
and people watching that sparring
footage would probably lean towards
cyril gone right sure so this is uh both
got good shots
yeah and so francis went on record
saying that the it was manipulated to
look that way right and this is his
response here
so he said i roll my eyes because it
makes no sense um fernand lopez said in
an interview then let's put it this way
let's take the worst case scenario the
ufc did manipulate the footage is it the
wrong footage why are you concerned
about the footage anyway it's the
[ __ ] footage you're not wearing the
four ounce gloves you're not trying to
knock zero gain down we all know i
recognize power shield gun recognizes
power the whole world recognizes power
they can see in the video that france
state uses full power to not gone out
right so where's the manipulation
this isn't my argument
i don't care about any of this [ __ ]
my thing is i don't if you just film
practice of your favorite boxer fighter
we have no idea what led up to that
sparring session again was was francis
sparring 10 rounds before that against
monsters was he doing a shark tank thing
where a fresh fighter came in every
round and then sargon goes in was
francis up all night with freaking girls
was he what did did he stroll in and
that's his first round so he's warming
up and they go francis here's cyril gone
he's like who's this then sergan
realizes francis he's going balls of the
wall france is just getting into it
but we're talking about practice that's
why to me i don't i don't give a [ __ ]
about any of that footage i know it's
something to talk about in the ufc likes
to use it but anybody in the fight game
doesn't put any any emphasis into that
striking footage
that sparring footage is whatever i i
need to know the background even with
the background i don't give a [ __ ] it
still doesn't sway my opinion that
francis can win this fight based off of
one sparring round
people putting too much emphasis on the
sparring match i need more details and
even if you gave me the details still
don't give a [ __ ] now
if you if you told me hey we gave these
guys a sick week six week notice get
ready for this one sparring round man
cyril lit his ass up like oh that's not
good still wouldn't really change me too
much so you want me to take the treeline
video this uh the video ends up with
francis ingano sitting down in the
corner of the gym because he ate the
knee of cirogana in the liver
knee on the body sat down he was [ __ ]
exhausted tired took the knee sat down
sir went tim brother come up let's go
let's keep going let's keep training
that's what happened at the end of the
video i think there's something special
that you did in the video please come on
talk
um i will show the video he said you
just ate the [ __ ] knee of a kid who
was in the gym like a couple months you
ate the knee and the liver sat down you
have to say he knows what the [ __ ] does
he know what the [ __ ] are you talking
about he knows what's up come on speak
up what are you talking about again
training [ __ ] francis killer friends
will knock everybody out
yeah
uh yeah again he landed a good knee
while the weather
you know
training
if i list off the amount of guys that
i've hurt in training
very famous guys that you would all know
that went on become champs
would it matter does it matter it's
training it doesn't count
i need i need to know the background of
what happened
to leading up to that round
that's it yeah basically there's so many
different variables there's no way it
doesn't matter
all right so
speaking of um
sparring sean strickland
i care according to their coach eric
nixon like he constantly wants to spar
with francis hold up and they're in the
same gym in vegas well i mean apparently
what
this is nick sick said this
uh yeah so the reason why strickland has
become a fixture extreme couture
i love working with them it just reminds
me of the old school day stream could
door to be honest when you have mike
pyle jay hiron these guys get get on
spark day that give a [ __ ] who you were
for your friends they were trying to
fight you every day yeah that's old
school that's how we were at grudge and
tk's though it didn't matter man it was
out for blood we're trying to knock each
other out sean strickland's a cut from
that cloth
it's just in 222 like the game's adapted
where it's more of a professional sport
so that's that's why in the nfl during
practice not trying to knock each other
out you know
it's just you take care of each other
but
there's something
there's something that i respect about
sean strickland who still fights like
this
these are the
these are the shooto box brazilian
shogun vanderlei silva you know these
are the black house days where
you know we'd have to go and spar with
verdum and the guy before you get
knocked out with a knee and have missing
teeth and my god [ __ ] dude i guess i'm
gonna do this you know it's just some
guys
i dig it it's cut from the the old days
but
is it the smartest way to conduct
yourself no it's definitely not because
especially in 2022 you're not going to
have a lot of training partners yeah i
do a little sparring anyway jim he calls
out francis out every sparring special
he loves to spar france because he goes
i want to feel as close to death as
possible i want to have that fear of god
in my heart every time i spar a guy like
francis
so sure we throw him in there and let
him get some rounds with francis watch
him and right now see roy nelson get
after it last week those two try to
knock each other's head off and here's
sean strickland
sean strickland big old smile air-to-air
you gotta love him man
he's freaking crazy with roy nelson and
roy i know
hard
i haven't heard from him in a long time
too yeah i think he retired i think he's
just doing his got everything
smart guy i'm sure he's making money
yeah but god sparks with roy nelson and
francis insane i know
and here's actually some sparring
footage of sean strickland ko'ing his
partner
sparring partner
and who posted this sean good question
let's take a look at the video first
steel mma
oh [ __ ]
someone said [ __ ] man
you break your toys it's it's tough man
yeah strickland's a decent sized
favorite too over uh homeboy it just
says it was leaked
he definitely i don't know who's he
sparring there no idea yeah
well at least you know what you're
signed up for when you fight him
especially in training as long as you
know
yeah i mean don't know and then like
jesus christ dude calm down it's get
shot strictly man there's always guys
like that in gym
you know after all these stories about
sean strickland and how like he wants to
like kill someone all the stuff i'm sure
his future opponents might seem some
sort of like aura about him now that
they didn't see before right
yeah the legend of sean's
building and i'm along for the ride i
know
what a crazy dude
uh this i thought was pretty crazy as
well so charles oliveira says that when
he fights because he can't wear his
glasses he's basically seeing three
people i know a few guys like this i'm
not going to out him but i just train
with a guy he would take his glass glass
off and he squint on how the [ __ ]
secrets i really can't that's why i
fight so close like how how do you not
get lasik dude [ __ ] didn't they say
like you couldn't do that or something
they said they just can't tell them i
always lied yeah i got it years when i
was playing football and then they had
asked like nope they don't they can't
yeah
uh never hinder me if somebody walk out
with glasses sometimes i walk in with
glasses depends on my vibe sometimes i
like to walk with glasses they look
harmless and more nerdy
and when i take my glasses off it's
normal i can see my point on the other
side god bless me so much i can see
normal but on the streets if i take them
off i'm blind
it's crazy because you have to do an eye
test
usually to
and also like if you admit this i'm kind
of like that's kind of not good to do
right yeah i know and he says he when he
fights he goes for the person in the
middle and usually that's what works
yeah god man the money you're making i
didn't get lasik dude and just not tell
anybody
there's there's even [ __ ] you can do you
can't do in america we can get better in
2020
there's a vision thing you can do where
it's like
special forces guys do it and other
people do it athletes do at a very high
level where it's it's like supervision
it's even higher than 20 20. i want to
do that so badly remember that thing you
talked about the drops yeah the so my
friend who's go for it go ahead oh my
friend who was an op you know eye doctor
he said yeah it should work well but
then you can't see that well at night so
i'm like [ __ ]
you just get lasik jim i don't know it's
just a distance
like up close that's it but if you had
lasik you don't have to worry about any
of that no more surgery no surgery
nothing so easy though really now you do
go blind for 30 seconds that's going to
freak the hell out the [ __ ] out yeah but
yeah
glasses are cool
yeah i don't mind them yeah my eyes
still suck at night oh really yeah
because one of the side like
side effects of lasik over the years i
think you have to get updated every 14 i
got mine over 14 years ago but at night
like it's like
i just thought it was foggy as [ __ ]
outside i'm like oh my god
i saw this fog i realized there's no fog
yeah and like the lights like and
i think it's because of lasik but my
eyes are super scent like
like people like why do you wear
sunglasses during food truck or if i'm
outside i have to have sunglasses on or
other i'll get the worst headache in the
world wow i can't see i have to have
sunglasses on at all times because my
eyes are so sensitive to light let's get
one of the side effects lasik but your
boy can see
at least you have at least you could put
on sunglasses it's not that crazy you
know that's good yeah
uh there's another one on oliveira he
said he would like to if he was able to
if he had the chance he'd go either down
for the belt or up for the belt he
should go up yeah yeah yeah
45 was at night but he wasn't great at
45.
um it'd be great to see him fight kamar
hussman and that's actually a really fun
matchup
really really fun matchup
and there you go
and this one i don't know how legit this
is but this is uh
apparently this is from boxing scene
that mayweather floyd mayweather is
supposed to potentially fight a youtuber
no floyd posted on his instagram too was
like it's there's only be a handful of
you know spectators and have you seen
the the yeah it's like on top of the
world now i'm scared of heights i'm not
even if
not that he's going to but even floyd
offered me a kick i ain't going to that
[ __ ] thing
but it's only be like the richest sheiks
in the world who have
more than billions of dollars watching
this thing so he's gonna fight this dude
yeah does he have any background he does
he has boxed before i'm not sure who
he's boxed for but i did see that he
boxed before
and he just looked he looks like a small
dude let me tell you how this fight came
together
some rich sheik
who's a fan of him
uh
was like hey man let's uh offer floyd
all the money in the world to fight you
it'll be a high profile fight for
yourself and he goes okay and that's us
and they called floyd like okay want to
make
80 million dollars to fight this
arab youtube kid and he's like yeah sure
yeah
it doesn't make sense one of the one of
the richest kids there so that means
he's insanely rich then
apparently some of those some of those
like kings like oil rich people
so you know the forbes is like the top
so you have like bezos and elon musk and
whoever on that list
those people in the middle of these they
they make sure their name's not on that
list apparently they have so much money
where it's like it's all like you know i
think they said
elon musk like the first trillionaire
apparently in the middle east they laugh
at us like really [ __ ] we got like 10
of them out here but they don't want
that record they don't want that
recognition they don't play those games
they make sure their name's never
involved in that stuff apparently they
have like unlimited money like how much
money having
what's more than a drill it you know
i'm sure somebody offered
floyd all the that's what if i'm floyd
dude
i would
if they offered me 10 million i'd fly
out to dubai and beat the [ __ ] out of
this 19 year old let alone if i'm floyd
mayweather at 46 where the hell he is 44
this kid doesn't have a shot
they've unfold why not do this weird
[ __ ]
it's a ton of money
his net worth is so
cf balsa owns the halsey group of
companies which said to have over 23
establishments his network net worth is
reported to be in the billions so
probably means he's like a trillionaire
and he probably offered fl i think if
you're
let's say he has
500 billion which he probably has more
say his 500 billion for him to go hey
floyd here's 100 million to fight this
19 year old was trying to get him more
yeah i mean 100 million to that guy's
not [ __ ]
now i'm floyd i'm like say last dude
i'll beat the show this 19 year old kid
um real quick when going back to jake
well this is a kind of silly but so
marvin vitoria called him out like to do
a sparring match with him that's not
gonna happen i got but this is a jake
posting about him doing kicks and he
says
first aid training kicks doubted every
step of the way but kicked down the
doors of the doubters then he tagged
bellator and pfl ufc
that was literally it yeah athletic kid
man yeah it's not terrible
i mean everyone doubted the whole him
fighting i know yeah and people still do
i can't even this day no one can he
can't doubt him
you never know
um
this i thought was interesting as well
jake bye now maybe he's just playing
games here says jake paul says tommy
fury doesn't deserve the fight i think
he deserves the fight had a legit injury
if you do want to fight a box chest away
dear god jake don't fight julio cesar
chavez jr
you're talking about a guy former
multiple time division champion an
actual boxing he's 53 and six that's not
what you want dude that's not what you
want yeah
please fight tommy if you're next you
know
win that and get
even more chavez officers junior that's
not what you want now you could bank on
him which hopefully he learned his
lesson financially in silva and get the
[ __ ] beat out of him he didn't really
train for that fight
and he got beat up
so i'm i'm
guessing the paul bros are like yeah
julio chavez jr he doesn't really train
me you can get them but that's not what
you want man
here's a real quick one uh cub swanson
after his last win he said that he would
be honored to fight uri faber right and
then i guess they they're both talking
like who the real king of cali is oh i
love that and then you're right faber
responded
directly afterwards in the press
conference that his dream fight would be
uh fighting palm springs against yours
truly he wants to drop to 135
and uh you know honestly
yeah i know he broke his hand that might
give me enough time to train he's gonna
drop down to 35s
we were supposed to fight back in 2004
with king of the cage on a short notice
for a thousand bucks i think we're going
gonna pay him a couple hundred bucks
a thousand bucks and uh that never
happened so
cubby
i i'm honored that i'm your dream fight
here in this scenario so uh we might
find out who the king of california is
directly afterwards i dig it it'd be
cool old school fight yeah go fight make
sense guys
yeah i mean even if uh
you're i were to lose that he's still
the california kid i mean he can't
one fight's not gonna get rid of that
but i'm all for it
is that it dude uh one real quick one
matt brown versus brian barbarina that's
a cool fight right there too uh ufc
columbian state for ohio boy yeah well
that's great for matt brown that's fun
yeah fun
is savage
yeah so you got a fight card this fight
night uh hell of a main event calvin
kader versus giga uh that's at 4 pm
pacific so that bad boy's gonna start a
little early
and uh yeah decent card brandon roy roy
val on there uh caitlyn trudeakins on
there jennifer maya never mad at
court mcgee brian kelleher our boy brian
kelleher is on there so
cards i'm gonna blow hair back something
to do for your degenerates but that main
event will guarantee you live up to the
hype that's a great fight somebody were
to get a knockoff home run they could
step in place to fight volkanovsky um
hopefully the ufc pays henry cejudo and
they announced that uh pretty soon here
not holding my breath for that but uh
enjoy the fights on friday uh as far as
housekeeping notes
again like uh subscribe to the thick boy
channel you get food truck diaries
cowbest fight campaign the shop show
everything is on there uh chappelle
lacey show is on there now we have a
bunch of cool [ __ ] dropping on thick boy
youtube so like and subscribe you guys
are doing that which can't thank you
enough obviously going on my own is
always scary but we're doing the goddamn
thing and then my version of patriot
patreon i'll tell you it's better it's
easier we offer more it's
thickboy.supercast.com
five dollars a month you get the thick
boy bundle you get the shop show cowbest
fight campaign food truck diaries ama
biweekly classic fight companion
episodes uh on there right now is me and
brian count bring down my fights in the
fc we're also gonna have sugar shawn on
there you get thick boy advance notice
on uh merch you get uh custom signed
autographs from all the artwork that my
boy
reuben does and then uh for an
additional three dollars you get all
that plus firing the kid ad free so go
to
thickboy.supercast.com right now
and uh yeah man we're taking all this
into our own hands not leaving up to the
man anymore and we appreciate you guys
following along liking subscribing
going through all these changes i know
it's a beast but we're doing the goddamn
thing for housekeeping notes um let's
see tomorrow night tuesday night i will
be at the comedy store first time back
to the comments from about two years man
since the pandemic i'm there i think i'm
in the belly room
doing jeremiah watkins stand up on the
spot there and then uh i will do another
set at the hollywood improv i think at
8pm
is that show so
get tickets to the comedy store if you
want to see me or the hollywood improv
and then shauban friends is back january
26 wednesday night 8 p.m one show only
this bad boy will sell out i keep
telling you guys that and then we get
dms you guys being upset we're gonna
have more shows in february at the
hollywood improv that's my spot now so
wednesday night 8 pm january 26th it's
shaman friends last shopping friends had
eric griffin brian callan chappelle
lacey
and uh chris de leo is a special guest
the 26th we have another very special
guest so you know it's going to be some
big boys showing up for me so come on
out hollywood improv los angeles
california jan 26
outside that man i'm taking all of
january off just doing spots around la
so you'll see me all over la for you
that live local
um next time on the road as of now we'll
have something else lined up but as of
now sacramento california at the punch
line in sacramento california one of my
favorite spots last time i was there if
you remember sacramento it's when you
guys had those uh fires the the fires
and there's smoke everywhere and
everybody canceled except for your boy i
got sick because i'm on stage sucking in
all that smoke but i still came out we
sold out the shows let's do it again
because there's no smoke that's february
24th through the 26th at the punchline
sacramento california get your tickets
now at f-a-t-k-z
com
and that's it kids thank you again like
subscribe to think boy channels you can
watch all my [ __ ]
go to the super cast it's
thickboy.supercast.com
be nice each other stay safe i love you
guys stay thick see you monday